joining us now is former white house
press secretary and co-host of
outnumbered kaylee mcinandy all right
kaylee you've been in more press rooms
than i will ever be in the president
just had a press conference twice he
said americans want to be safe
no reporter asked him to follow i didn't
hear a single question about crime so i
mean is the media that disconnected from
it's the number two polling issue are
they that disconnected from it
yes they are and i'll tell you why trey
you know i regularly in the briefing
room proactively brought up crime crime
began to rise on the last year of the
trump administration it correlated with
the defund the police movement i believe
there was a causal effect there and we
brought up crime we brought up the issue
to reporters i regularly named the
names of children who lost their lives
in the streets like sequoia turner
police officers like david dorn i mean
the press would just simply not ask the
question not only that john carl wrote
some op-ed that said one of the most
troubling parts of my briefings was when
i called out reporters for not bringing
up the issue of crime he said you know
the administration had not put forward a
policy on crime and therefore no
reporter would ask about it well about a
week after he wrote that op-ed we put
forward operation legend to which i got
precisely zero questions in the briefing
room they ignored the issue because
unfortunately it just doesn't fit the
ideological agenda of the white house
press corps and i think that's sad
because it ignores the american people
and the plight that they face
you mentioned operation legend there is
a role for the department of justice
most crime is state and local that's a
given
but but there are plenty of federal
firearms and other offenses the federal
government could get involved with let
me ask you this quote politicians on
both sides are are reluctant to
criticize their bases and and and i get
that
but but you got some progressive
prosecutors and you got some members of
the house that are saying absolutely
insane things like closed federal prison
biden
and the democrats are going to get
swamped in november if they don't find a
way to speak out against that aren't
they
absolutely it's the number two issue to
registered voters in the fox news poll
so they will get swamped if they don't
fix it and they can at least play a part
you're exactly right trey as we all know
these states hold the police power these
da's are the biggest part of the problem
but you have a president who can call
out the da's who was in new york city
who could call out d.a bragg who as
harold suggested could surge federal
resources fbi personnel to these states
as operation legend did ending in the
arrest of nearly 500 criminals who had
committed homicide so there are things
the federal government can do
but yes you know it's the states it's up
to them and you have a president who can
call the states because after all these
days are members of his own party
right well he may not can control the
d.a in los angeles or the d.a in new
york but he can darn sure control
merrick garland and i don't hear a lot
coming out of the department i heard him
get really tough on parents in virginia
really really tough i have not heard
merrick garland maybe he's i'm not
watching the right shows but i hadn't
heard a whole lot from him about the
rise in violent crime have i have i
missed that no
no no you haven't missed that right
because it hasn't happened but what he
did upon coming
into office you had a.g garland who came
forward and what did he do he dropped
half of the cases against the portland
rioters those rioters who were throwing
literally fireworks into a courthouse
where federal officers were he dropped
half of the cases you had a president
who rolled back the executive order that
president trump put in place about
anarchist jurisdictions that we will
deprive you of federal funding if you
don't enforce the laws on the books so
there are things that that this
administration has done to make the
problem worse and you're exactly right
to put the onus there on a.g garland
kaylee thank you for joining us tonight
we'll see you tomorrow on outnumbered i
hope have a good evening hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else